thank you
there is um
nothing
more difficult and subjective
than assembling five
extraordinarily gifted actors and
choosing one of them to receive an oscar
but we must remember the stated purpose
of the founders of the academy back in
nineteen twenty seven
this award
was to serve as a constant incentive
so holding that thought
we will remind ourselves
of the stunning work done this year by
these five artists
gene hackman the mississippi bernie
tom hanks for big
dustin hoffman for rain man
edward james almost for stand and
deliver
max von sidao for bella the conqueror
and the oscar goes to
dustin hoffman for rayman
um
thank you
thank you very much
uh
i'm supposed to be i'm supposed to be
jaded by this point
i'm i'm very honored and i thank the
academy for your support
and i
and i also thank
uh tom hanks and
max foncito and james almost and
my good friend gene hackman for their
wonderful work even if they didn't vote
for me
i didn't vote for you guys either
it's it's a pleasure to be here with
with such good work
uh
i i thank
my agent mike ovitz and tony thermopolis
for making this project stick with glue
when it was falling apart i thank all
the producers i think the wonderful cast
and the crew of this film who were so
emotionally connected with us i i thank
the writers barry morrow and ron bass
and and i just want to thank all the
people i talked to
uh
that were autistic and their families
and the doctors and and all their help
and that our associate producer gail
mutrix got a hold of us
got a hold of for me to meet
particularly kim peek who was the first
inspiration of the film joe sullivan and
his and his mother and
and my
my my my special thanks to
peter and kevin guthrie
my
father
so wanted to be here tonight
ironically a few weeks ago he joined the
family of the disabled and i understand
that at the hospital where he's
at tonight that a lot of people that
i've met recently are gathered with him
with
tuxedos and
champagne cups and formals and they're
all watching the show right now on a big
tv that they rented
so to the
just a few weeks ago that he was at the
golden globes and he says let's find
gene hackman because he knows we're all
roommates come on that's fine gene
anyway
to the to the wonderful doctors and and
nurses and
rehabilitation people and to the
families that i've met recently and
and to my father
and to his new friends here's looking at
you thank you
you